YouTube made a big announcement YouTube  has announced they will soon begin  offering live and on-demand TV to  compete directly with cable companies  now a lot of people are not sure if  users will pay for YouTube after  watching it for free for so many years  but YouTube just released an ad for the  new service and it looks like they  haven't forgotten what their customers  really want take a look  YouTube TV is coming soon it's  everything you love about YouTube Plus  live TV and all the premium channels you  demand we've got the Gulf channel ESPN  the et Cartoon Network the action Chen  Animal Planet  The Weather Channel  of course the tough dad Network YouTube  TV ouch right in the TV  [Applause]  you